[Musique]
bonjour josette manin
bonjour monsieur livory vous avez été
élu samedi député de la première
circonscription de la martinique celle
du centre on l'a beaucoup répété depuis
votre élection vous êtes entré dans
l'histoire de la vie politique de la
martinique à double titre un première
femme présidente du conseil général et
les dernières président d'un conseil
général de la martinique et première
femme député de la martinique vous subo
je suppose que vous êtes très fier vous
avez réalisé là il faut bien que je
réalise un puisque depuis samedi
effectivement je suis lui sept députés
là qui a été voulu par les électeurs la
circonscription du centre atlantique que
je salue d'ailleurs je voudrais donc
saluer tous ses électeurs et électrices
et électeurs et puis je salue toute la
martinique mais écoutez j'ai été
candidate à ces élections
j'ai je crois avoir travaillé avec donc
les électeurs de la circonscription pour
en arriver à ce résultat et ben je peux
dire aujourd'hui que je suis fier d'être
ce 7 députés qui était tant attendu par
la population martiniquaise
on a vu bien çà mau passé vous félicite
et on a senti beaucoup d'émotion à ce
moment là une grande fierté aussi
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
on vous a vous a beaucoup parlé vous a
dit quoi écoutez je dois bien ça vaut
tout s'est tu
toute la richesse de cette vie politique
que je porte depuis déjà quelques années
même si je n'ai pas débuté ma vie
politique aux côtés de pierre samot
puisque comme j'ai comme je le rappelle
je suis entre en politique en 83 avec
toute une bande d'amis autour de georges
gracia et ensuite en 95
je suis revenu après une
une courte pause comme j'ai tendance à
dire je suis revenu donc aux côtés de de
pierre samot et tout au long de ces 25
30 années de vie politique
c'est aux côtés de pierre samot que j'ai
parcouru donc ces années c'est pierre
samot qui m'a proposé en 2001 d'aller
aux élections cantonales plus puis en
2008 et pierre samot a été également
l'artisan de ma candidature au poste de
président de la collectivité
départementale
donc forcément pierre samot et moi c'est
une grande histoire d'amour politique
une grande histoire d'amitié de
l'amandinois et je crois que la première
personne vers qui je me tourne
après un tel résultat ça doit être pire
ces mots vous voyez comme un exemple
pour les femmes à la martinique
absolument vous savez si je n'étais pas
un exemple pour la martinique
cela veut dire que je n'aurais pas cru
en ce que j'ai fait ça veut dire que je
n'aurais pas je ne serais pas revenu
après décembre 2015 pour pouvoir
représenter la martinique représenter
les femmes anti nicaise
je veux croire que à travers moi les
femmes de la martinique puisse demain
même tout de suite se dire bon ben il ya
un avenir sur ce territoire nous devons
effectivement être présente aux
présentes aux côtés des hommes aux côtés
des hommes politiques de façon à pouvoir
travailler pour le pays martinique mais
ce n'est pas à la traîne quand même on
célèbre aujourd'hui en 2017 d'élections
d'une première femme députée
tout le monde est content tout le monde
rit on y re 2017
mais bien sûr qu'on est à la traîne
c'est justement parce qu'on est à la
traîne que j'ai voulu être là que
certaines ont voulu être là même si
elles n'ont pas été élu mais je crois
que on a tellement répété qu' il fallait
rattraper 500 sans pouvoir rattraper et
la guyane et la guadeloupe et la réunion
il fallait absolument qu'on passe le cap
il fallait qu'on a une femme qui soit
qui représente donc notre territoire
sur le plan national
donc je crois que l'on ne va jamais à
rattraper ce qui s'est passé dans l'est
sur les autres territoires ultramarins
mais enfin on va décoller enfin les
femmes pourront se dire mais oui on peut
y arriver
voilà il était temps près de 80% des
martiniquais ne sont pas allés voter est
ce que son ce sens madre cela légitime
face à cette forte abstention
vous savez une fois qu'on est il lui on
illégitime
à partir du moment où on est quand même
dans les bus si si on peut être source
oui voila moi je dis que cette
abstention est une abstention quasiment
nationale qui devient même presque
mondial maintenant parce que il n'ya pas
les lectures ne se raccroche plus à aux
politiques que nous sommes une vraie
fracture
s il ya une fracture est ce qu'il ya une
perte de confiance est ce qu'il y à une
méfiance
il ya certainement il y à une rupture
entre nous politiques et la population
donc moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
eu tellement d'événements il ya eu
tellement d'affaires dans cette
politique là que j'ai comme l'impression
que cette rupture là l élan corp pour
quelques années donc je crois qu'il y a
ce travail là que nous appelons de nos
voeux à faire auprès des populations de
façon à redonner confiance
mais vous savez tout le monde le dit et
il faut trouver justement la manière de
le faire
il faut trouver la manière d'intéresser
le la population à la change de registre
justement va revenir sur cette la
manière les propositions mais ce que est
ce que l'abstention c'est pas aussi une
forme de résistance
oui on peut dire que c'est une forme de
résistance mais une existence pourquoi
une existence à croix puisque la vie de
tous les jours et fait de politique
quasi mais les hommes politiques
aujourd'hui les hommes et femmes
politiques ne sont ne sont plus audibles
oui mais justement c'est qu'il faut
changer le disque où il faut changer la
manière de faire il faut justement avoir
cette proximité là auprès de la
population de façon très pédagogique à
pouvoir leur démontrer que tous les
jours nous faisons de la politique et
que de toute façon la vie de nombre
d'une femme de l'enfant qui va à l'école
c'est de la politique donc je crois que
nous avons à faire en sorte que la
confiance revienne et que de toute façon
dans les années à venir les prochaines
échéances
quand laurence r go la confiance
revienne par exemple on voit les jeunes
les jeunes n'ont pas été on était
quasiment absent du débat politique de
dhiba de législatives de toute façon moi
ce que j'ai à dire c'est que les jeunes
ont quand même on a vu quand même une
proportion de jeunes notamment parmi les
candidats c'est déjà quand même puis
mais les jeunes candidats d'accord mais
les jeunes se sont si l'avenir c'est eux
qui sont qui demain qui sont appelés aux
urnes
et là aussi on parlait d'être audible on
a l'impression que ça lui glisse sur sur
le coq sera là mais oui mais c'est la
chose positive c'est le constat qui a
été fait et moi moi je dis que même si
certains à des opa nouvelle méthode de
qui se met en place avec le président de
la république mais je pense que ne
serait-ce que ce ce nouveau mode de de
goût de gouvernance va peut-être donner
confiance aux jeunes va permettre vous
avez vu que à l'assemblée nationale il
ya un certain nombre de jeunes on vient
de voir par exemple qu'à une jeune fille
de 24 ans qui est il eu ça permettra ça
redonnera certainement le goût à ces
jeunes là de pouvoir quoi on les jeunes
de leur âge et de pouvoir justement
adhérer à cette manière le faire ça veut
dire quoi qu'est ce que vous entendez
par là le fait d'être une de ni de
gauche ni de droite de faire appel ne
sais pas si c'est parce que vous voulez
non non non c'est simplement de voir la
division justement l'adhésion des jeunes
à cette méthode de gouvernance
et puis bien évidemment cette nouvelle
manière de faire comme vous dites ni
droite ni gauche mais cependant je
revendique quand même l'appartenance à
un parti politique on peut être dans un
gouvernement être en marche mais on ne
peut pas renier du jour
mais son adhésion à un parti politique
moi je suis une femme de gauche je reste
sur une femme de gauche black compatible
la fameuse question de la question pour
vous la centième fois qu on vous
l'accordé il y un président de la
république qui est élu on est là
justement pour être des représentants de
notre territoire
aux côtés de ce président ou dans ce
parti dans une autre partie je dis bien
de gauche
dans un autre groupe de gauche pardon et
donc moi je pense que de toute façon le
travail que nous avons à faire c'est
certainement ou représenter dignement la
martinique et non pas toujours se poser
la question
de toute façon la question se pose mais
on y répondra assez vite
oui vous avez une réunion d'ailleurs ce
soir ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle pour aborder ce sujet quels
seraient les critères pour être macron
compatible pour un somme pour martin va
vous avez deux député serge letchimy à
fort-de-france et vous même
oui la question ne se pose pas ce sens
la question se pose certainement plus
tôt donc en matière d'objectifs pour
notre pays c'est à dire que nous allons
porter certainement un certain nombre de
revendications de projet et je pense que
ça va être la division à nos projets qui
nous qui qui qui va nous être odieux
dans un groupe que ce soit maquereau ou
un groupe de gauche mais moi je pense je
parle en projet je parle en projet parce
que je ne veux pas non plus a dit reid
ans dans ce gouvernement est ce qu'il va
être être du bord du président et du
gouvernement pour faire avancer ses
projets mais attendez c'est pas c'est
pas simplement être dans un gouvernement
qui permet de faire avancer des projets
on peut être dans un groupe
d'opposition pas une opposition stérile
et puis pouvoir présente ici projet
faire avancer ses projets et se faire
entendre sur tout alors le député du
nord bruno nestor azérot il celui du sud
jean philippe muller s'est de plus de 6
des deux députés pardon lancé un appel
au rassemblement des quatre députés pour
faire parler d'une seule et même voix
pour défendre les dossiers de la
martinique vous dites quoi
vous savez c'est ça a toujours été ma
manière de faire de la politique je les
jeux les pratiques et au conseil général
c'est à dire rassembler les forces vives
d'un pays où parler d'une même voix
je les dis pendant la campagne
électorale je m'inscris justement dans
cette démarche de rassemblement de
l'ensemble des parlementaires déjà des
quatre députés de façon à ce qu'on ait
une démarche commune pas forcément des
projets communs pas forcément des
dossiers communs mais connaît une parole
commune et que l'on puisse giuntini 3
même avant de partir à s'asseoir à
l'assemblée nationale qu'on ait des
échanges en qu'on se parle et qu'on
puisse définir une ligne politique poule
pour le territoire
vous avez été élu député samedi ça y est
david zobda peut se préparer pour les
municipales m'écouter vous savez le
l'objectif des municipales haïti clair
au lamentin 6 il faut parler du lamentin
le meilleur plan sambou qui est donc
l'actuel maire de la montée jusqu'à une
date donnée à fixer les objectifs
il fallait que je vous êtes manea y donc
sur ces élections législatives ça y est
c'est fait mais il sait david zobda qui
est le candidat pour les prochaines lois
passées croche pied entre temps ben la
croche pied je sais pas de qui il
viendra mais pour ma part vous savez
j'ai je suis dans une droite qui une
ligne droite politique au lamentin chez
nous tout est l'engagement que j'ai pris
c'est un engagement que je vais tenir
vis-à-vis de pierre samot vis-à-vis de
dabistes david zobda josette manin je
vous remercie bonne journée sur notre
antenne
c'est moi qui vous remercie je bonne
journée à tous les auditeurs
[Musique]
dexter